Jag tror också att det är väldigt viktigt att bygga ett bolag som inte är personberoende på det sättet.
Det får liksom inte bara luta på en person, för då är det svårt att köpa en sån verksamhet.
Värdet minskar ju någonstans ganska brutalt om du har byggt upp ett bolag runtomkring enskilda individer.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Peter som har grundat bolaget DPJ Workspace.
Det är ju ett stort företag idag, ett riktigt företag så att säga.
Men jag tror inte alla känner till det.
Det är liksom ingen medial grej som sprutar ut LinkedIn-reklam och Instagram-reklam.
Så Peter, kan du berätta lite för oss alla färskningar om hur riktig business egentligen görs?
Oj, tack Joel.
Det var en fina ord.
Riktig business, jag vet inte vad jag ska säga om det, men det är väl så att jag tror att man aldrig riktigt blir...
Jag tror inte att jag tycker att vi är färdiga på något sätt när det har kommit till den delning av att kalla oss för ett moget och väl utvecklat företag, även om vi har hållit på i många år.
Och det är väl som du säger, vi har haft en otrolig tillväxtresa.
Senaste åren från 2019 växte väl från 160 miljoner till 450 miljoner och sånt.
Och det finns väl en naturlig del till att inte alla känner till oss och det är väl väldigt mycket kopplat till vårt sortiment.
Jobbar man med kontorsmöbler och kontorsinredning så är det primärt företag som är målgrupperna.
Det gör väl kanske att vi inte på samma sätt syns i Instagram och sådana flöden.
Kan du tycka att det är lite skönt att jobba med företag som kunde?
Jag gillar att jobba med kunder rent generellt.
Jag ska säga att min person för att driva företag kommer ju kring att leverera en köpupplevelse och att jobba med hög tillgänglighet.
Sen tror jag det är ganska sekundärt egentligen vem som är målgruppen så tillvida.
Men det är klart att nu har vi verkat inom företagsförsäljning i många år och det är en stor skillnad.
Det är stor skillnad på att jobba med företag och privatkonsumenter.
Vi hade en stor del av privatkonsumenter under den här berömda pandemin som vi har lämnat bakom oss.
Jag tänkte att vi måste komma in på den sen.
Det blir ju, även om vi som var med i det tänker på ett visst sätt så kommer det bli ännu konstigare när vi ska berätta, eller jag ska berätta för mina barn här om 20 år, att vi stängde ner samhället.
För de kommer det bli som Spanska dig i döden, hela samhället var nedstängd.
För oss är det ändå lite, det är mer som en märklig händelse.
Jag tror att det blir ännu konstigare i historieskrivningen.
Men skitsamma, vi ska inte fastna där.
Kan vi inte börja lite, för du började det här bolaget för länge sen.
Nu kanske jag inte får säga, men då var jag nio i Bast.
Hur började bolaget?
Varför drar man igång kontorsmöbler?
Ja, det kan man faktiskt fråga sig.
Jag är ju Norrlänning sen, det kanske har varit med mitt dialekte också, jag kommer från Gällivåre, och är väl första vänster en obotlig entreprenör.
Jag startade mina första verksamheter uppe i Norrland och flyttade ner till Stockholm för 31 år sedan.
Jag trodde att jag skulle ge mig in i en restaurang eller hotellnäringen för att jag älskar just ämneservice och att göra kunder glad av att man har levererat någonting bra.
Så det var min illusion vad jag skulle göra.
Men när man kommer ner så måste man ha sett försörjare sig också och jag gav mig in och började jobba på ett företag som sålde kontorsmaskiner.
Jag såg ganska snabbt att man hade helt fel fokus, man jobbade mot en målgrupp som var måttligt intresserad, men så fanns en annan målgrupp som ringde in och verkligen ville ha varorna.
Så att den här entreprenör-
genen i mig gjorde väl då att jag såg att det här kan man göra bättre och annorlunda och jag startade då egentligen.
Bolaget inledningsvis hette DPJ Kontorsvaror.
Där sålde vi då kontorsprodukter primärt och det var målgruppen skolor runtom i både Sverige och sen expanderade vi internationellt med det.
Men efter ett antal år så kom jag tillbaka till det här med att jag älskar att ge service och köpupplevelse och att leverera vissa typer av, assortimentet hade vuxit och det var mängder av kontorsprodukter i assortimentet.
Men att leverera en palkopieringspapper såg jag inte hur jag adderade glädje och lycka och energi till människor med den produkten.
Vilket då gjorde att jag helt egoistiskt sammankallade vårt årande ledningsgrupp och sa att jag hade förberett mig ganska väl och förklarade under ett helgevent att vi kommer att sluta göra det vi gör.
Vi kommer att börja sälja kontorsmöbre istället.
Jag tror det var många som skakade på huvudet och tänkte, va fan ska du sänka det enda vi lever på.
Hur var verksamheten då?
Hur stor var den då när du bara, vi byter spår?
Den var nog, jag kommer inte riktigt ihåg omsättningsmässigt, men jag skulle säga att det var cirka 50 miljoner och sånt kanske.
Ni hade ändå ett gäng personer för du sa ledningsgrupp här.
Ja, då hade vi ett gäng och det skulle vi säga ledningsgrupp nummer 50 personer är ändå en begränsad del kring, men det fanns ju ett antal intressenter som ändå hade någon form av säljchefsroll eller olika positioner.
Jag tror jag lyckades förklara för alla under den helgen att det här är, vi placerar och kommer att bolagisera den verksamheten i någonting annat, det som har kvar kontorsvarudelen och sen fortsätter DPI med möbler och vi adderar och växer det sortimentet.
Och det var faktiskt där fick jag lite gärna den här stimulansen åter kring att när vi levererar ett kontor så är det lite grann som för våra kunder att kliva in i en ny bil.
Man kan känna, wow, jag är glad och nu känner jag att jag har fått en lyft, jag har fått en förbättring på min arbetsplats eller i min arbetsmiljö.
Så att det tycker jag har varit jäkligt kul.
Är du nöjd med era egna kontor?
Ja det är jag.
Jag ser bakgrunden, det ser ju slick ut därute i alla fall.
När man jobbar med det här så blir man lite skadad kanske.
Man börjar tycka om vissa formgivare och man börjar gilla våra kontor är nog bland det dyraste man kanske kan inreda.
Det ser lite platsbyggt ut där eller liknande.
Det ser invävt ut i väggen och de där lamporna hänger ju inte utanpå.
Nej, precis, det är som sagt, vi måste ju någonstans föregå med gott exempel.
Vårt kontor besöks av arkitekter, inredare, företag som ska göra större förändringar.
Då vill vi naturligtvis att man ska se att vi kan det här vi jobbar med.
Då kom passionen lite därmed att få inreda kontor, kan vi väl säga då.
Tog businessen stryk av det i början eller bara fortsatte det?
Nej, det gjorde det inte.
Vi har egentligen aldrig tappat momentum, utan vi har, ju tydligare vi har blivit, ju mer fokuserade vi har blivit.
Det här var inte första gången vi tog ett beslut att gå i en lite tydligare riktning.
Så varje gång vi har gjort det så har vi fått bra effekter av det vi har utvecklats som företag av varje fokusering beslut.
Och det är nog någonting som man kan ju lite grann befasigt i hand kan man säga det att det som tog mig 30 år att göra hade inte behövt ha 30 år att göra.
Om jag hade veta vad jag höll på med, men jag hade inte sprungit på alla dessa bollar under resans gång, så jag tror att man kan göra det här på 6 år, 7 år.
Spelar det någon roll egentligen?
Känner du att fan varför gjorde jag det inte på 6-7 år?
Eller känner du att det har varit rätt kul?
Nej det har varit så jäkla kul.
Vi har haft så jäkla roligt och vi har gjort så mycket saker som nu när man tittar på DPI så är DPI ett väldigt städat och renodlat företag som jobbar med att inreda kontorsmiljöer.
Men under resans gång har vi gjort så otroligt mycket andra saker och testat olika koncept och testat även lite andra avstickande verksamheter.
Ge oss någon avstickare så vi får...
Vi kan väl säga så här att när vi under tiden när vi jobbar exempelvis med kontorsmaterial så hade vi också någon del där vi sålde fastighetsklimatprodukter.
Vi hade någon annan del som tog hem mopeder och eventuella motorfordon från Asien som man har.
Ja precis, vi har kört så otroligt många olika branscher.
Vi har sålt något inom något annat inredningsföretag som sålde konsumentinredning.
Vi har sålt bastuflottar, vi har fastighet gjort allt tror jag.
Bastuflotten, var det den som pitchade den idén?
Var det inte bara, det var ju någon som ville ha det till en svensk exa och bara fuck it vi köper in en bastuflotte så att vi får köpa in den billigt.
Jag vet inte hur du sa det, vi har testat så många olika grejer och gjort det med någonting, kanske med den grunden av att vi har haft en ganska stark marknadsföringskompetens alltid i bolaget.
Så vi är väl ett väldigt marknads-
och säljinriktade.
Och med den kompetensen, när du sitter på så djup kompetens inom marknadsföring och försäljning, så blir du inte så rädd för att prova olika saker.
Och du vet också att det här kan vi göra.
Man gör någon liten test inom olika saker och det kan vara mer för en egen form av stimulans kanske.
Men vi ska inte fastna över det där, utan de senaste 15 åren har vi varit väldigt renodlade och jobbat i en mer tydlig riktning.
Kan du ta oss igenom de här senaste 7-8 åren, för att även om ni kanske växte procentuellt ganska snabbt innan så är det ändå en ganska stor, kraftig tillväxt att gå från till exempel 160 till 450.
Det blir väldigt mycket mer produkter.
Hur hanterar man den uppskalningen i volym?
Åh herregud ska jag säga.
Det är en mycket relevant fråga.
Vi får säga att växa så snabbt är ju ingenting som en kanske, även om det är väldigt stimulerande när man gör det, så är det också extremt utmanande.
Men om vi börjar tillbaka till varför jag tror att vi har lyckats på det sättet och tar den tillväxtresan, det är väl mycket kopplat till att vi försöker jobba med tillgänglighet, att ha produkter hemma som kunder faktiskt efterfrågar och behöver i sina, oavsett om det är projekt eller om det är till ett hemma kontor.
Och sen också att tillgängliggöra det här genom att vara, man kommunicerar så enkla saker som pris och möjlighet att beställa online.
Det är ju i vår bransch, den har vi inte legat längst fram, utan många har gjort köp och sen är det alldeles för komplicerat.
Man har truppt att kunden behöver träffa en säljare och prata om inredning för att kunna göra en transaktion.
Medan vi har varit inne på den delen och sagt, men herregud att köpa en kontorstol, ett skrivbord, hur svårt kan det vara liksom?
Kan vi beställa en bil online och designa med klädsel och så?
Så det här är ju ganska odramatiskt.
Vilket gör att när vi har varit så tydliga, medan alla andra då kanske har jobbat med att man ska kontakta dem och så ska man få en offert.
Och så tar det tid innan man får rätt pris.
Men vi har ju sagt, ge kunden rätt pris på en gång.
Visa produkten och vilka produkter du kan få omgående leverans på.
Det är liksom inte rocket science, utan det är något som fungerar i alla branscher, men inte riktigt har implementerats i vår bransch då.
Är era bransch lite sådär som Soffor, du vet man väntar sex, tio veckor på?
Ja, så har det varit rent generellt i måndt och mycket totalt det här.
När företag ska flytta och man kontaktar en leverantör, så kan det ju ofta vara så att det är beställningstider, de håller inte hemma ett sortiment.
Medan jag tycker då att vi är de som är specialister som ska kunna det här.
Då ligger väl oss då att säkerställa att vi har rätt produkter på hyllan som kunden faktiskt behöver.
Det är inte så att du ska behöva välja mellan 10 000 olika kontorstolar och olika textilier och vad det nu kan vara för någonting.
Utan vi ska faktiskt veta vilka produkter som är bäst för kunden.
Det gör att vi kan slimma sortimentet, vi kan hålla det hemma, vi kan säkerställa att vi köper in det i de volymer som är optimala för våra tillverkare, vilket gör att vi kan säkerställa en bra prispill till kunden också.
Och det är väl de insikterna, vårt sätt att arbeta, att arbeta med tillgänglighet, både vad gäller hur vi är transparenta och tydliga mot kund, och hur vi säkerställer att vi har de produkterna på hyllan som har gjort att vi har fått den här explosiva tillväxten.
Hur har ni hanterat kapitalbindningen under de åren?
Det är ju inte en stol ni lager och håller.
Nej det är ju inte det.
Och det är väl inte så att jag rekommenderar någon att ha den explosionsartade tillväxten.
För att som entreprenör, på den tiden när vi gjorde den här resan, så var jag den som var ägare av verksamheten.
Om jag är ägare så innebär det också att man har det fulla ansvaret.
Och har man varit entreprenör och driver bolag så är det ju det man gör, det är det man har någon form av person runt omkring.
Man har ju försökt lösa eller måltvingats till att lösa alla de här delarna vad gäller kapitalbindning och vad gäller lagers omsättningshastighet och allt sånt för att få det här att snurra.
Tvingats vara väldigt agil i sitt förhållningssätt till hur skall vi...
Säg vad du verkligen tänker nu.
Nej men alltså det är verkligen det är mycket ångest många gånger runt omkring att ha den här tillväxten vilket gör att du kan liksom inte stanna båten heller utan det är bara full gas framåt.
Du måste ju sälja ännu mer för att klara av den här finansieringsdelen också.
Jag tror att folk missar det, exakt det du säger där.
Om du har stark tillväxt och du inte har jättemycket pengar så är ju sättet att finansiera lagret är ju att sälja ännu mer vilket bara förstärker hela situationen så att det är på ett sätt hopplöst.
Ja men det har varit en otroligt lärorik resa.
Alltså man lär sig otroligt mycket av att göra det vi har gjort.
Så fantastiskt kul.
Jag kan personligen tycka att det finns många bra fördelar med företagskunder.
De gör ju ofta större inköp och de kanske är mer återkommande.
Det är alltid lättare att sälja i bulk.
Men en av de hopplösa grejerna är att ifall någon nu ska inreda ett kontor och de ska inreda helt plötsligt 140 kontor, då ska de köpa 140 sådana uppsättningar.
Helt plötsligt säljer man slut på det man inte hade räknat med att man skulle sälja slut på, för det kom ett bulkinköp som förstörde hela prognosen, för de vill ha samma stil på allihopa.
Hur hanterar man den märkliga, speciellt efter covid situationen där det kanske var mer privatpersoner som köpte en sån och en sån och en sån, och helt plötsligt kommer det att vi vill ha 500 sådana.
Hur hanterar man lagerhanteringen?
Ja, vi kommer väl egentligen från det andra hållet.
Vi kommer egentligen från projektförsäljningsdelen där vi hade de här konstanta höga vågorna där ett företag skulle ha en större mängd arbetsplatser levererat.
När vi sen kom in i pandemin och vi plötsligt stod inför att några av Sveriges absolut största bolag ringer och frågar kan ni leverera 7 000 arbetsplatser hem till våra anställda.
Då säger man ju som entreprenör, då svaret är ja.
Den utmaningen var nog större än att hantera de här vågorna som man får i projektförsäljningen.
Kombinationen däremot av att säga ja till de här företagen som behöver jättemycket privat hemleveranser plus att mängder av privatpersoner valde att börja beställa online och de här höga vågorna, det blev en utmaning.
Och hur hanterar man det?
Jag tror att vi hanterar den och det är relativt, efter våra förutsättningar på ett ganska bra sätt.
Vi har säkerställt att vi alltid ska ha goda lagerkapaciteter.
Men däremot så var ju leverantörsledet under pandemidelaren inte riktigt redo för att hantera här.
Vilket satte oss i svåra situationer naturligtvis.
Okej, det var inte ni internt som hade problem att dela upp ordrarna i 7000 olika ordrar, utan det var framförallt logistikbolagen som hade svårt att hantera.
Nej snarare våra leverantörer.
Vi har ju ett eget lag.
Okej, bakåt, okej jag fattar.
Vi hanterade det väl, men våra leverantörer mäktade inte riktigt med efterfrågan.
Och även om vi fick löften om leveranser så var deras leveranser i sin tur försenade och så vidare.
Så att vi hade, det var en utmanande period.
Blev det en bromskloss där?
Hade ni kunnat gasa på mycket mer om det inte hade hänt?
Eller är du glad att det inte blev en bubbla där som sen blev svår att leva upp till?
Det var nog tur att vi inte växte mer.
Det får jag säga.
För att vi hade redan kunnat leverera hur mycket som helst.
Vi hade kunnat omsätta 7-800 miljoner under de här om vi hade haft tillgång till allting.
Ibland när man hör entreprenörer snacka så säger vissa att man vill ha stark tillväxt och andra säger att man vill bygga långsiktigt och stabilt.
Du har ju gått igenom lite båda faserna, du vet.
När folk säger att de vill bygga långsiktigt och stabilt och andra bara gasar på.
Vad är det man missar när man gasar på?
Vad är det stabilt betyder egentligen?
Stabilt betyder att man vill sova gott om natten, man vill ha lite annan kvalitetstid med sin familj, man vill ha lite andra delar, man värderar andra saker än bara företagandet på det sättet.
Jag tror att ur mitt perspektiv så är jag kanske lite mer, jag gillar på något sätt den här matchen av att vi ska utvecklas, att vi ska kunna ta marknadsandelar, göra någonting bättre än det övriga aktörer gör och någonstans har jag nog också som under de här åren som vi pratade om pandemiåren, när det fönstret så stod öppet så jag hade nog svårt att säga nej till den möjligheten att faktiskt ta den tillväxtdelen.
Det är många av våra konkurrenter som valde helt andra vägar och egentligen stängde dörren och sa nu stänger vi verksamheten.
Medan vi istället sa wow, vilken möjlighet, nu kör vi.
Det är en inställningsfråga.
Ibland önskar jag att jag skulle ha den här delen av att tänka att vi skulle köra saker och ting långsamt istället.
Okej, är det mängden magont som framförallt avgör?
Om det är snabbt eller långsamt.
Ja det kan det nog vara, men samtidigt är det naturligtvis, jag skulle säga, idag är vi mycket mer strategiska i vårt arbetssätt.
Vi jobbar ju inte, men att gå igenom en sådan resa som vi har gjort nu med de starka tillväxtåren, har ju varit väldigt utvecklande.
Jag tror att det vi vet idag och det vi kan idag med olika typer av utmaningar som kan uppstå, gör att vi är bättre rustade idag än någonsin tidigare för att hantera liknande situationer.
Vilken del av, ska jag kalla det här då, när man går från, vi säger 100 miljoner då, till upp mot, när man börjar prata i miljard istället, så man säger en halv miljard eller en kvarts miljard.
När man börjar komma upp lite grann i de där riktiga, då känns det som att folk börjar använda sådana här uttryck som strategiska beslut och, du vet, vi jobbar på en mer övergripande nivå.
Vad av det är vettigt och vad är det bara flum, vad är det folk faktiskt borde syssla med som är konkreta och faktiskt ger någonting?
Och vad tycker du folk bara borde slatna av i det där?
Ja, jag tror att det är nog olika delar.
Jag tror när du börjar rattan skjuta som har lite högre omsättning så blir det ju så många parametrar som måste följa med här.
Det gäller ju dels att, det första som händer när man växer såhär snabbt är att man måste anställa en massa människor som klarar av att göra, att hantera hela den här tillväxten.
Sen måste du börja titta på vad gör vi nu egentligen?
Nu har vi väldigt många, hur ska vi bli mer strukturerade och mer effektiva och hur kan vi automatisera i större grad för att klara av att få en lönsamhet på de här tillväxttalen.
Men det kommer per automatik en form av hur man vill eller inte, så kommer det någon form av strategiska insikter.
Att man måste börja jobba mer planerande, du måste kanske kliva in och ta en annan höjd.
Det arbetet är väldigt viktigt ändå, ska jag säga, att ta den delen och ta den tiden kring att faktiskt sätta sig ner i något säga, skapa en ordentlig ledningsgrupp och att jobba med de delarna så att vi, vad gör vi nu, vart är vi på väg?
Och den förflyttningen då som vi är på väg att genomföra, hur ska vi genomföra den, vem är antan svarig, när ska det genomföras?
Det är inte så komplicerat, även om du kallar det för strategiska dokument så är det väl fortfarande så att någonstans är det något vi egentligen i mångt och mycket, kanske även privat borde göra.
Det här borde vi använda mycket mer i vår vardag, att jobba mera med planera, sätta upp dina mål, tydliggöra hur du ska nå dem och fördela arbetsuppgifter.
Det blir väl någon form av strategidokument av det där.
Jag ska sätta mig med min fru här ikväll och fördela.
Hur många kollegor är ni nu?
Vi peakade ju på 106, sen har vi gjort precis det jag sa och så har vi gått igenom och tittat hur kan vi rationalisera, hur kan vi effektivisera, så nu är det väl ungefär 70 personer.
Hur många av de 70 måste tycka att DPJ Workspace är det bästa som finns i livet?
Ja, jag skulle vilja säga att alla dessa människor hade den åsikten.
Samtidigt så har vi ju gått igenom en ganska stor förändring.
Dels att vi har tagit en mycket tydligare position kring att vi har ett primärt fokus på att hjälpa företag.
Vi har minskat antalet konsumentordrar så tillvida.
Har tagit en tydligare avstamp i att det är företagskunden som vi ska fokusera på.
Det är klart, förändrade den personalstyrkan från 160-70 personer så är det många medarbetare som lämnar verksamheten och det är kompisar till någon.
Det blir inte lika lätt att känna varje dag att allt är på topp, tills man gör en så stor genomgripande förändring.
Men det jobbar jag med varje dag.
Jag har själv en väldigt stark förespråk, att man måste ha en kultur på företaget som är oerhört viktig.
För mig som grundare vill jag verkligen att människor ska trivas här och må bra på dagarna.
Det är oerhört viktigt för mig.
Kan du inte ta oss lite genom den här resan?
För du har sålt delar eller hela av bolaget idag?
Jag sålde hela bolaget 2022 i december blir det.
Ja precis, det är snart tre år sedan som jag sålde hela bolaget.
Kan du inte ta oss igenom den?
För då hade du jobbat med bolaget i 20...
Ja, 20-70 år blir det.
Det måste ju vart en resa.
Ja, det var det väl.
Vi hade väl inte någon egentlig tanke på att sälja bolaget, utan däremot blir det när man börjar nå vissa omsättningstal så börjar man bli kontaktad av olika intressenter som ser det här.
Man märks på marknaden.
Det börjar väl med att vi blir kontaktade av någon utländsk aktör.
När man väl börjar med mentalt accepterande tankar, kanske inte vore det så dumt.
I kombination med att man har en extrem tillväxtresa och man känner att det skulle vara skönt att ha med sig någon som hade lite mer kapital för att kunna sova lite mer, sova gott i nätterna.
Så det tog väl kanske ett halvår för mig att börja tänka i de barnen efter ett antal samtal med olika intressenter att vi kanske ska titta på den delen.
Och det utminnade är att vi satt med en väldigt stor aktör bland annat då.
Så vi hade jobbat med en DD-process under ett halvår.
Och vi var, med den aktören var vi tre dagar ifrån att signa.
Allting var klart.
Och plötsligt så avbröt processen.
Och så satte vi igång med någon ny aktör.
Så vi gjorde också den här resan, det var 2022 som sagt var första gången vi var på väg att att göra en försäljning var i januari, februari, ja januari 2022.
Och sen dök det upp fler aktörer under resan och vi hade fler aktörer på gång.
Fan vad jobbigt det är.
Ja jag kan säga, om det är någon som ska sälja sitt bolag och blir uppvaktad så skulle man gärna vilja ta med all de erfarenheter man har fått nu, skulle man gärna vara med och guida och hjälpa till och på något sätt försöka ge en lite nyktersyn på det här.
Som entreprenör så, man kan ju bygga bolag, man har byggt bolag men man kanske inte har erfarenhet av att hur jobbar jag med en försäljning av bolaget och vad behöver jag tänka på och hur kommer de här olika köparna att agera.
Vad är det du skulle skicka med om du bara fick skicka med lite grann?
Jag skulle nog säga att, först och främst så, allt du gör måste finnas någon form av dokumentation på.
Se till att ha med dig en bra transaktionsrådgivare.
Du kan inte göra det här själv.
Det är total livsfarligt.
Utan ta med en bra transaktionsrådgivare.
Se till att ha bra människor runtomkring dig som stöttar i den här processen.
Visst, det kostar pengar att använda dem men det här har vi inte gjort tidigare själva så att den kostnaden för den erfarenheten är ovärdelig.
Du känner tillbaka det både i huvudvärk och pengar?
Absolut, absolut.
När du efter lång processer hade gått igenom det här, hur gick känslan sen för att du är ändå kvar på bolaget?
Ska du vara där?
Blev du upplåst något år eller var det bara nej jag kör här för nu är det tre år senare.
Ja precis, jag tror att ingen av varken köparen eller jag visste vad som skulle hända i en framtid efter den transaktionen men det är ett familjeföretag som köpte hos och jag har väl känt en stor lojalitet runt det varumärket och det företag som jag byggt upp och jag vill verkligen göra det bästa för det här företaget.
Om det är det sagt så säger det även till de nya ägarna att jag stannar gärna kvar och kör vidare om ni tycker att jag har gjort ett vettigt jobb.
Sen är det väl ingen som vet hur framtiden ska se ut här men jag tycker det är kul och den utmanande delen kan naturligtvis vara att ha drivit verksamhet i 20-70 år så har jag ju ganska ofta stått och pratat med mig själv i spegeln och fått väldigt korrekta svar och gjort allt som jag tycker är, det här verkar vara väldigt logiskt.
Sen när du välsäljer verksamheten så får du in en extern styrelse, du får in en ägare som du känner ett ansvar emot och du får ju förberedare på att börja jobba på ett annat sätt.
Du måste också ha en förståelse för att de nya aktörerna eller de nya intressenterna i styrelsen har inte samma kanske förståelse för verksamheten och verksamhetens utmaningar eller möjligheter.
Men jag älskar att lära mig saker.
Jag tycker det är så jäkla kul varje dag när jag kan känna att wow nu har jag lärt mig någonting nytt igen.
Det är egentligen, så i det är det ingen större skillnad med att vara, om man bara har den inställningen så att säga så oavsett om jag kör som entreprenör eller med kör som anställd, vd och så.
Jag blir väldigt stimulerad av att bli utmanad kanske både i styrelser och umman.
Det låter ju som en förvånansvärt nykter inställning till arbetet och livet men det måste ändå vara märkligt att gå in i en styrelse och så ska någon ifrågasätta en punkt som är varför gör vi på det här sättet?
Du måste ju några gånger vilja säga bara håll käften det gör vi, sluta ifrågasätta den jävla punkten, den funkar så bara.
Ja, det är klart att man ibland kan känna att det kan vara utmanande att inte alla har samma förståelse för verksamheten.
Men jag tycker väl ändå att det har gått bra, och just det här att du tvingas till att förklara saker och ting som kanske är naturligt för dig gör väl också att du bara ifrågasättar att tvingas förklara någonting gör att du bollar även det här med dig själv.
Det här, okej, låt oss ifrågasätta det.
Kan vi göra det på ett annat sätt?
Nu tycker jag att vi har kommit till en punkt där vi alla någonstans börjar få den insikten att det faktiskt är företaget ser ut.
Alla har kommit mer in i företagets modell och hur vårt erbjudande ser ut, hur kunden ser ut och hur de agerar.
Så att idag känns det bra.
Du sitter i lite olika styrelser och sådana här grejer.
Jag såg något bolag som heter Bristly till exempel, sen vad det exakt är och sånt där.
Men är det företag som är inom den här större koncernen eller är det externa?
Ja, jag sitter dels, det är just det där systerföretag som är i det här.
Men jag sitter i lite andra saker också som du kanske har sett där.
Det är väl det att jag är en obotlig entreprenör.
När man är det så tittar man hela tiden på olika typer av möjligheter som dyker upp där.
Det jag har gjort under det senaste året är väl bland annat att jag har köpt en matproducent.
Som man gör.
Ja, som man gör, ja.
Jag har köpt en fabrik som jobbar med matproduktion.
Där är inte jag, jag har bara en styrelseroll där.
Jag ägar det men jag är inte operativ.
Där har jag anställd vd och så vidare.
Jag har även köpt ett, någon annan rimlasterat transportföretag som gör mig lite specialtransporter vilket jag också tycker är kul.
Så där i ligger det att jag försöker för att få utlopp för det där jag kan göra på lördag och söndag också och efter klockan 18.
Men känner du inte att du ska hålla dig i någon samma genre eller bransch?
Matproducent, okej på något sätt logistik har du säkert jävligt bra koll på men matproducent kan ju inte ligga i någon samma?
Nej det ligger absolut inte i någon samma del och jag ska väl säga att det snarare där har stimulerats av, det är väl kanske här att det är en annan bransch och att jag får möjlighet att lära mig någonting nytt.
Att jag får möjlighet att förstå de villkoren att jag får möjlighet att också vara med och bidra till att vi har en hållbar matproduktion i Sverige.
Att vi, det kan vara minst eller väldigt viktigt under dessa osäkra förhållanden som vi har lärt oss att leva i de senaste åren här.
Absolut att du tycker det är kul.
Vad är det de letar efter när de, och jag menar det på det mest kärleksfulla av sätt, men vad är det matproducenten och transportbolaget här känner att det här vill vi ha Peter för?
Jag tror att det är mer av de här insikten av att kunna bygga ett bolag när man har gjort det på en annan nivå.
Att ta ett bolag till en viss omsättning, det är många som har den erfarenheten.
Sen att växla upp att gå ifrån de här, ja det är matbolaget omsatt ungefär 60 miljoner, alltså sportföretaget ungefär 100 miljoner och sånt, men att gå därifrån och växla upp det till nästa nivå, då krävs det kanske att vi börjar implementera lite andra arbetssätt och börja jobba mer strategiskt, kommer vi tillbaka till, och mer med det här med att man har en eventuella målbilder och sätta upp handlingsplaner för hur vi ska nå de här delarna för att när man är upp till en viss storlek av bolag, då kör man ju bara.
Då är det vilda väst och man går mycket på magkänsla och det kan man göra till en viss nivå.
Därefter så behöver man börja agera på ett annat sätt och det är väl det som de har tyckt att, kul, nu kanske vi kan få ett annat perspektiv på det här.
Det är ju ofta, eller jag nästan anade att det svaret skulle komma, men var det någon som var där och hjälpte till när du skallade upp?
Nej, inte det.
Fanns det inga fördelar med det?
Det gick ändå bra.
Ja, det gick ändå bra.
Det gjorde det.
Man kan säga så här, absolut, om jag hade haft det kapitalet att kunna känna att jag kunde köra lugnt, eller att jag hade kunnat köra på i min takt, som absolut inte är lugn, men hade kunnat köra på i min takt och känt att vi hade haft det kapitalet att göra det med egna medel, då hade vi nog kanske inte tittat på en typ av försäljningsdel.
Men jag tror att som entreprenör hittar man hela tiden lösningar.
Det som är skillnaden nu med det är att nu ingår vi i en annan typ av koncern.
Vi måste tydliggöra vår position och vår roll.
Det kan inte vara lika mycket Vilda Väst än längre.
Det är klart att jag hela tiden kan hitta affärsmöjligheter i olika galna upptåg.
Men för att vi ska bli det här riktiga företaget som du inledde med att säga, så är det ju det att där måste vi bli väldigt strukturerade och tydliga.
Men vart är vi på väg?
Vilka mål vi ska nå?
Vart är vår position om tre år?
När du tog första samtalet med investerare, var det för att du kände dig lite smickrad?
Eller var det för att du tänkte att jag kanske ändå säljer, eller tänkte att jag kommer aldrig att sälja men det är ändå kul att bli uppvaktad?
Nej, jag tror att jag jag har liksom inga sådana här attachments till oavsett om det är ett värdepapper efter 27 år.
Jag gillar den här kaffekoppen jag har.
Jag kan kliva ifrån en bostad, ett hus och säga att nu är det nästa grej.
Jag kan sälja ett bolag och göra det att nu är det nästa fas utan att egentligen bära någon form av ånger eller känna att jag har gjort något felaktigt till slut.
När jag väl kör så kör jag.
Så jag blir inte så sentimental runt omkring olika sådana förändringar.
Jag köper det, det är väl lite ovanligt men det är en jävla positiv fördel att ha.
Finns det någonting som du kan se från, eftersom du har suttit på båda stolarna, har både fått in folk som har köpt och du har köpt in dig i vissa drag som man som investerare letar efter?
Finns det vissa green flags som är så här, det här vill man ha i bolaget eller entreprenörerna?
Ja, jag skulle väl, jag vet inte riktigt, frågan är ganska bred men om jag tänker mig ur ett, om man nu sitter som entreprenör och man funderar på att sälja sin verksamhet, så kan det vara ganska bra om man börjar med att strukturera lite gärna, titta på att man har koll på allt.
Har jag en tydlig affärsplan, har jag den så att jag kan presentera den för en möjlig investerare som tydligt beskriver att bolaget är på väg någonstans.
Har jag koll på alla aktiebrev, har jag de delarna på plats, kan jag när som helst förklara hela verksamheten och de olika rollerna och vad de fyller för funktion, kan jag förklara vad det är marknad bidrar med, vad det är produktkategori bidrar med.
Alltså att man verkligen har koll på sin egen verksamhet.
Det tror jag att det är många företag som inte har det.
Att vilja sälja ett bolag, det kan ju kännas som att ens bolag är värt hur mycket som helst, men mycket av det baseras runt i kring att det faktiskt finns den här strukturen.
För när du säljer ofta som bolag, de allra flesta som gör det kanske väljer att göra något annat efteråt.
Och jag tror också att det är väldigt viktigt att bygga ett bolag som inte är personberoende på det sättet.
Det får liksom inte bara duta på en person, för då är det svårt att köpa en sån verksamhet.
Värdet minskar ju någonstans ganska brutalt om du har byggt upp ett bolag runt kring enskilda individer.
Med det sagt då, vad är din största roll i DPJ idag?
Vad är det du bidrar med som mest?
Ja det är nog, det kan man ju faktiskt fråga sig.
Jag tror att vi jobbar väl, jag kan säga sen den här processen av att vi hamnat in i en större koncern, så ser mitt arbete lite annorlunda ut.
Vi har fått in fler personer som också har roller i företaget för att kunna driva bolaget framåt, även om inte jag skulle finnas på plats.
Jag försöker ha en mer strategisk höjd, försöker jobba mycket med riktningar, vart är du på väg, vad ska vi göra, försöker möta alla de här sakerna.
Jag är väl också en e-handelsnörd, så jag sitter och jobbar väldigt mycket med att vara marknads och e-comm team.
Jag har väl inte på det sättet kanske någon annan tydlig roll i mitt vd-skap, och att jag är väldigt marknads-
och säljinriktad och försöker leda de delarna framåt.
Är det farligt, nu fastnade jag i det, jag tänkte egentligen avsluta här, men är det farligt att vara ett marknads-
och säljorienterat bolag?
För du har sagt det några gånger, när blir det en konflikt mot produkt och logistik och liknande, att ni får för mycket att säga till dem?
Allting måste ju komma utifrån kundens efterfrågan.
Här tycker jag att det är viktigt att det egentligen är marknad och sälj som på något sätt styr sortimentet.
För det är där vi har en kunskap och en insikt om vad kunderna frågar efter.
Om vi låter en produktutvecklingsavdelning styra vår portfölj så kan den lätt spåra ur.
Då kan det lätt bli produkter som är alldeles för tekniska eller alldeles för komplexa som egentligen inte sitter i ett kundbehov.
Det här kan väl också vara svårt när man tittar på inköp och sortimentpositioner.
Jag tycker det var svårt att få in rätt att koppla det till marknadsdelar.
Att göra själva funktionen att köpa in, det är inte så komplex för personen.
Att hitta de här nya produkterna som vi kan addera värde till vår fortsatta tillväxt, det är ju en...
För mig kanske det känns ganska enkelt, för jag har gjort det här länge, men det är inte självklart för en person som kliver in och ska axla den rollen.
Är det marknadsföringsteamet som sitter och väljer nyheter eller letar fabriker, eller har ni produktspesade människor som gör det?
Vi har ett inköpteam som gör det.
Samtidigt har vi också i många fall Seli som initierar någonting på grund av att man kanske har en kundförfrågan, ett större projekt där vi måste ha vissa produkter i det projektet.
Man kan väl säga att vi har egentligen två olika delar av sortiment.
Det ena är ett renodlat online sortiment som ställer krav i mångt och mycket från marknad och e-com på hur det ska se ut.
Men det är inte de som köper in utan det finns ju andra som sen sitter och köper in.
Och sen har vi det andra benet om vi tittar på projektförsäljningen som är mycket mera, ja där kan det vara föreskrivet vissa typer av produkter som vi måste ha just till den leveransen.
Vilket fan vad jävla resa du har gjort.
Stort tack Peter för att du var med i podden.
Sjukt intressant att få höra hela, ja jag älskar ju sånt här, när man bygger ett riktigt bolag och man har kört länge och så får man liksom skala det över tid och folk får vara med och man får bygga det från insidan.
Jävla resa och kul med försäljningen att du har gjort alla steg och även fortsatt.
Sjukt spännande, tack så jättemycket.
Tack så mycket Joel, fantastiskt kul.
Är era bransch lite sådär som Soffor, du vet, man väntar 6-10 veckor på...